in this video we're going to introduce
ourselves to a new way of visualizing
atoms and as you can imagine from the
title here that's going to be Lewis
diagrams but before I even get into that
let's do a little bit of review of what
we already know about bore models so
let's say we take an arbitrary element
here let's say we take nitrogen nitrogen
by definition has seven protons and so
if it's neutral it's going to have seven
electrons so a bore model for nitrogen
in our first shell that first shell is
going to look just like helium and it's
going to have two electrons so let me
draw it like that and then in its second
shell its second
shell it is going to have the remaining
five of the seven electrons and we are
going to make them unpaired at first so
1 2 3 4 and then five the reason why I
did it this way is a full veilance shell
is is going to have eight electrons or
four pairs but if the electrons can
spread apart they like to spread apart
so that's why I did 1 2 3 four and then
I paired this last one because there's
nowhere else for it to actually go now I
just touched on this issue of veilance
electrons those are the electrons in
your outermost shell and they tend to be
the ones that are involved in reactions
so chemist said hey you just for a short
hand instead of having to draw all of
this every time why don't we just
visualize the veilance
electrons and so let's do that in this
nitrogen example so a Lewis diagram
which is I'm just going to draw right
now is that simplified visualization
where you write the the symbol for that
element and you just depict its veence
electrons we just saw that there are
five veence electrons for nitrogen seven
total but five veence five electrons in
that outermost shell so it is going to
be 1 2 2 3 4 and then five so that's a
Lewis diagram for a neutral nitrogen
atom it turns out we can also do this
for ions so let's say that we had a
nitride ion over here now a nitride ion
has gained three electrons so it
actually has eight veence electrons so
if you gain three from five you're going
to have eight so I'll go one two three
four five six
7 8 and because it gained three
electrons from being neutral it now has
a negative-3 charge and so you'll often
see it written like this where they put
back they put brackets around it and you
would see three minus now the last thing
that you might wonder about is okay I
kind of understood how you got the
veence electrons for nitrogen is there
just some general pattern in the
periodic table and the simple answer is
yes and that's one of the useful things
about the periodic table or as we'll
learn there's many many other really
interesting things about it if you look
at the groups in general you're going to
have one veence electron for group one
elements for this column over here
you're going to have two veence
electrons for these group two elements
and I know what you're thinking okay is
just the group the number of veence
electrons well unfortunately it doesn't
exactly work out that way I'm going to
skip the transition metals here because
those get a little bit more complicated
it's a little bit more advanced but then
if we go over here to what is this group
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 Group 13
over here is going to have three veence
electrons group 14 four veence electrons
five veence electrons in group 15 and
that's why we saw five veence electrons
for nitrogen here six for group
16 seven for group 17 and then 18 for or
sorry I should say eight veence
electrons for group 18 so one way to
remember it is for groups 13 through 18
you take the group number and you
subtract 10 and you're going to get the
number of veence electrons and hopefully
that made sense based on how we were
able to figure out the veence electrons
for example nitrogen